Now let's begin today's video. *Respect your Wamen*
There's a reason I have edgar *hit* as a guest here today.
Because todays theme is: *RESPECT*.
Thank you marklepooper.
Not just every form of respect.
But respect wahmean.
Respecting wahman is no joke.
It is no joke to joke about.
That cat needs those pills and so does wahman need *RESPECT*.
Edgar is still a teenager
I need to teach him.
How to properly respect wahman.
Are You paying attention edgar?. *ded*
Allright He is paying close attention.
Cool, well lets do this.
This is me when I respect wahman.
If You ever see me do this.
That means I am currently respecting wahman.
I dont know about you guys but Ive got a lot of respect for wahman.
One day edgar, my son, You will be able to respect wahman just as well as I do.
Are You listening?
Thank You, thank You edgar.
Respecting whaman is not a joke.. ok?
And I want You everyone to (ehh) everyone to follow my lead and ahh.
Give me Your best respecting wahman pose right now as You watching.
Thats it.
Respect wahman, respecting wahman one punch at a time. dont hit wahman.
But dont hit guys too... JUST PUNCH A LADY THEY LOVE ITTTT.
Edgar You... You finish the video, You say something good.
Let me put on some nice music.
*Edgar Singing*
*Outro*